when you left i was not very optimistic
about chances but the guy played king g8
why on earth you play king james why are
your d5
yeah d5 looked like most
and we see table image here is gandalius
the hero from yesterday who grinded the
same game
for more than six hours he looks in big
trouble
against xiong you see it's all about
nerves
who catch shade is threatening let's
have a look at the position i will put
the position it's stable to finish
such a calm and uh
very nice guy uh
this world cup are just for the nerves
it just gets to everyone i saw even in
my match against malachov
i saw some sign on of extreme
nervousness on malachov which is
amazing actually because malarhoff is
also very calm guy
um but that was such a rollercoaster
that's
okay sometimes i will i will look for
nils i i saw it
sorry a bit lower but okay i think he is
i know what
no but he's about to resign after bishop
e5 it looks
it's just blended yeah okay
let's see the position here and this is
stable
so how did it we have the position here
bishop c3 queen e3
i just missed would be here said bishop
p5 very simple trick
to thank to mate and if you take here
take attack zook mate is coming
no defense no defense
disgusted neil stakes on e5
queen takes e5 will be played
and there is no moves
yeah you will he will resign here stable
25 will be played on news
we expect uh handshake here
yeah yeah resign
okay stay back tomorrow pt for news
after such a great game yesterday
uh that was amazing this queen ending
uh very very complicated but he finally
he found his way by
at some point he couldn't calculate till
the end but it was
he was choosing the only option to keep
the game going and
it proved to be the winning
the only winning uh line that was
amazing